نجوا من هول الكارثه ورائحه الموت لم
تتلاشى بعد من تحت كل هذا الركام خرج
بعضهم سليما او باصابات طفيفه لكن اخرين
لا تزال تطاردهم لعنه هرس الاطراف
وتهدد ببتر اطرافهم او حتى الموت هذا
الطفل البالغ من العمر ثلاث سنوات يدعى
الب ارسلان بري نجا من الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب تركيا وشمال سوريا في السادس من
فبراير الجاري لكنه سرعان ما فارق الحياه
بسبب متلازمه هرس الاطراف
حاله حال الكثيرين ممن اخرجوا احياء من
تحت الانقاض
متلازمه هرس الاطراف تنتج من ضغط تتعرض له
اطراف الجسم لفتره تزيد على 12 ساعه ما
يؤدي الى انقطاع الدوره الدمويه على مستوى
الانسجه ويعرض المريض للبتر والاصابه
بقصور كلوي ثم مشكلات في القلب
ضغط الوزن الهائل لانقاض المباني المدمره
ادى الى اصابه بعض الناجين من الموت
بمتلازمه هرس الاطراف ما جعل القائمين على
الوضع الصحي يرسلون صرخات الاستغاثه
المصابين بشكل عام ووضعهم سيء جدا بحاجه
الى رعايه طبيه فائقه بحاجه الى اجهزه
بحاجه لمستهلكات ادويه لا طاقه كانت تكفي
للتعامل مع هذا العدد الكبير من الاصابات
اغلب المرضى الذين كانوا يوصلوني يوصلون
بحاله
الضغط بسبب الناتج عن الابنيه والاسقف
التي كانت تساقط على اطراف
متلازمه هرسل اطراف لاحقت هذه الطفله ايضا
شام البالغه من العمر تسع سنوات نجد
باعجوبه بعد انقضت نحو 40 ساعه تحت
الانقاض لكنها تواجه تهديدا قاسيا ببتر
قدميها وهي الحاله نفسها التي تعانيها
الطفله جنان ذات الخمس سنوات
يمكن تجنب الاصابه بهذه المتلازمه من خلال
عدم سحب الشخص مباشره من تحت الوزن الكبير
الذي يضغط على اطرافه اذا مضت عليه اكثر
من اربع ساعات
وبدلا من ذلك يوضع رباط ضاغط على الفخذ من
الناحيه القريبه الى البطن او على الساعد
عند الابط ثم يتم سحبه حتى لا تعود السموم
الناتجه عن هرس الطرف الى الجسم وتسبب
الفشل الكلوي كما يقول متخصصون بالمجال
الطبي
تواجد تحت الانقاض لفتره طويله ينتج عنه
ما نسميه متلازمه هرس الاطراف لذا نعمل
على منعهم من الدخول في الفشل الكلوي
نتعامل بشكل خاص مع اصابات الاطراف تجنبا
للوصول لمرحله بتر هذه الاطراف الاوضاع في
المناطق المنكوبه معقده جدا وبالاخص في
مناطق شمال سوريا حيث يعاني مئات المصابين
في الزلزال من حاله هرس الاطراف وهم بحاجه
لرعايه طبيه متقدمه لكن القطاع الطبي منهك
بشكل كبير الامر الذي دفع البعض ولا سيما
فرق الخوذ البيضاء الى اطلاق دعوات عده
للوقوف مع هؤلاء الاطفال وجميع المصابين
بمتلازمه الهرس
والاستجابه العاجله لتلك الحالات